Hello, Japan
I know how popular Hugh Jackman's fabulous dancing monkey musical is in your beautiful country even more popular
Than Deadpool which filled me with murderous jealousy
Since I couldn't beat the Clawed wonder I decided to join him by turning my new sequel into a musical. That's right
Get your tickets now for Deadpool two
the musical critics are calling so profound
It doesn't even feel like a musical because it's not actually a musical
Talents
Your bullets they're really fast
David Beckham speak its like he mouths sucks can of helium
Am so sorry so so so
Tickets for the cup. I can't wait to not watch Italy play the Netherlands.
Can't stay mad at you Healing hugs. Here we go. Oh God, finally that feels so good. You smell amazing
like cinnamon and manhood
No, no, no. No, we should let go so let go this burden together. Just wonderful
No, okay, would you apologizing for anyway, we're just the bit and Deadpool with the your voice
Doesn't ring a bell
What did you think I was apologizing for? I mean, there's a list Green Lantern. Yep, RIPD what selfless terrible blade Trinity?
Sorry, I know they raised my voice I lost control
You